plus tu mens mois ce qui est arrivé hier
à québec dans la mosquée musulmane ou un
québécois est entré armé et que tirer
dans le dos des gens qui faisaient la
prière mais ça m'a même à vous raconter
mon histoire de moi même un québécois et
d'un marocain musulman qui demeure au
maroc pour montrer que de l'amour ya
encore de l'espoir pour un monde
meilleur pour parler de mon ami hassan
zaoui qui est mon ami facebook
hassan est tombé sur une vidéo
l'année passée on est devenu amis
facebook
on a discuté en privé prenez changé on
se raconte nos vies un moment donné au
fil des discussions il me dit qu'il y
avait des oliviers qui demeurait la nord
du maroc
et puis qui cultivait les olives enfin
de l'huile qui cultivait la figue le
carreau et puis qui vivaient très
simplement dans les montagnes du maroc
mais au fil de discussion ben j'ai dit
il me dit ça se pense au mois de
novembre l'accueil
j'ai dû aller vous est dévoilé au maroc
ou moins d'une semaine
mais mon frère soit le bienvenu mais
intense avant le fait que les et le
moussem reste leur taille
finalement mégi est omar un jeu télé
chez eux s'attendent avions le montréal
à casablanca
ensuite quatre heures de train pour
aller dans le nord du maroc jusqu'à la
ville de fès où hassan m'attendais un
autre deux ordres texte qui prône encore
plus dans nord du maroc dans les
montagnes
j'ai passé une semaine de raï rapide
amour de simplicité à ce n est pas de
voiture eux deux hommes préfèrent les
commissions pour transporter les olives
les grosses poches de livres une vache
qui donne son lait ils font leur propre
bar font leur propre pain j'ai marché
tellement de la bonne bouffe fait avec
amour
j'ai eu la plus grande chambre de la
maison j'ai été traité comme un roi
j'ai été traité comme un membre de la
famille je me senti bien tout de suite
passé une semaine magnifique quand vous
dis à salles aujourd'hui c'est plus
juste mais facebook ton frère justin
honte pour ces enfants
je suis longue québécois sa conjointe ne
s'appelle touria les quatre enfants deux
filles 2 go yasmine hayette des deux
garçons fadel et aller
donc c'est ça bon j'ai pris mes billets
au début les gens m'ont découragé
j'avais mes billets avec royal air maroc
les avec ma conjointe mais elle avait
trop peur d'être heureux c'est que on
était habitués du local inclus boas
république dans les buts incluant je la
comprends avec ne pas marquer la date je
te respecte aussi les membres de la
famille de monaco de mon entourage m'ont
découragé puis je les comprends avec
tout ce qui se passe à planète le
terroriste les enlèvement lire alençon
les coupables de pas du tout
la chienne de pony puis raymond bien
d'avions gecas et les mobiles aidant
même journée j'ai parlé de sa famille
étaient bouleversés mais voyons donc
pense personne moi je prends un voyou
pour un terroriste ne veux pas de mal
mouna matin le doute s'est installé je
me disais plus haut niveau les ja
mondiaux nous frisons facebook est
pratiquement rien su c'est un faux
contre la montre car je me disais tout
est correct je refuse ma décision j'ai
rappelé royal air maroc j'ai repris mes
billets dans même journée que j étais
inquiet dans la part mais je dis je peux
pas reçu ma part puis je vaux mais j'ai
pensé la plus belle semaine de ma vie
dans la simplicité dans l'amour la joie
aujourd'hui j'ai de la famille au maroc
je suis un oncle québécois et jeffrey
maroc et qui s'appelle hassan zaoui et
d'un marocain musulman
oui à 20 mosquées dans les montagnes je
me personnes me force à l'est le mois ne
même pas parlé il ya vait l'appel à la
prière
quatre ou cinq fois par jour je peux
vous êtes la première minute soit un
saut avec des haut-parleurs dans les
montagnes mouche dormait dans la chambre
dans le noir total que je pense qu'ils
étaient trop à 4 heures du matin de sa
pensée allait le mieux
la bande me re l'autre se réveille tout
ça y est c'est le coupage de paille tu
fait pour mourir
mais non c'était l'appel à la prière
pour me laisse que la même à terme
éleveurs car je ne m'en a dit c'est quoi
cette voiture qui sortait de nulle part
l'acsta mon histoire que je vais vous
raconter de québécois qui est moi et de
marocains musulmans qui s'appelle hassan
zarrou pour vous montrer que de l'espoir
il ya de l'amour sainte anne est
tellement je vous aime et on mange pas
bye